-My first guest
is a four-time
Golden Globe-nominated actress
and a "New York Times"
best-selling author.
She's also the co-founder
of a new wine brand,
called Avaline,
which is available now.
Here is my pal, Cameron Diaz!
Hey!
Aww.
I miss your face.
You look great, buddy.
-Thanks.
So good to see you.
I can't believe this.
I was hoping to come
see y'all this summer.
-I know.
'Cause I haven't --
We haven't seen you
since you had the baby.
-Nope.
-How is it being quarantined
with the baby?
-Heaven.
It's been heaven, Jimmy.
You know. You just got to spend
four months with the girls,
and you get to have every
moment, and it goes so fast.
And you really don't understand
that when people
have always said to me, you
know, "Really enjoy the time
when they're babies.
It's the best."
And literally, every single day,
there's just --
there's leaps and bounds,
and these things that happen
that she's not the same baby
she was yesterday.
-Yeah, I know. People always
said that to me, too,
and I was like, "All right,
all right, all right."
They're like,
"No, it goes fast."
I go, "I understand.
I heard you."
And, gosh, they're right.
-Where was -- What --
Where was yesterday?
Yesterday is literally gone,
and today is a new day,
and tomorrow will be a new day
that she's a completely
different baby.
But it's so gratifying to
actually get to see that growth
and to be a part of it
and to help
just let her be her,
and it's just amazing.
I just --
It's the best thing
that ever happened
to both Benj and I.
We're so --
We're just so happy.
-We were so happy
when you called us.
We were just crying
and jumping up and down.
Has your photos on your phone
completely changed?
-[ Laughing ]
I mean...
Well, first off,
the sad thing is that my phone
used to be pictures of my dogs
and my dogs' poop.
Because I have four of them.
You know that you're just
constantly sending pictures
of your dog poop
to your veterinarian, going,
"Is this normal?
Is this okay?"
Now, thankfully, I can say
that my pictures are no longer
of my dog poop,
and I'm also gonna say
they're not of my child's poop.
-Oh, that was my next
follow-up question!
[ Both laugh ]
The pediatrician's
getting pictures now.
-We're very confident in being
able to decipher her poop,
'cause it's very similar to...
-Oh, are you --
are you doing the whole --
all the movies and the shows
and "Baby Shark."
Is that happening in your house?
-Oh, my God.
-Let me just tell you,
it's literally,
we have "Baby Shark" on
rotation, we have Elmo's song,
we have "Sesame street."
-Yes.
-It's crazy. We're just
jamming out over there.
-Get ready for that --
-The thing that
I don't understand, like,
you go, "I will never
play that music for my child.
That's crazy."
But you watch their response,
and they're so taken by it.
It's like she changes.
She's like -- [ Gasps ]
"My people!"
[ Both laugh ]
-Isn't it the greatest thing?
Honestly, we --
My kids are little late
to the party,
but they're getting into
Disney songs right now.
It is Disney princess,
Idina Menzel all day long.
And when that song came out,
at first, you know,
we were making jokes
and all this stuff.
Can we stop listening
to the song, "Let It Go"?
It's the best song in the world
to watch your kids sing the song
and get into it
and close their eyes.
It's my favorite --
I love it.
Dude, I'm so the opposite
where I was.
It's, like, all changing.
-When we go on car drives,
Benj will put on Cuban --
Afro-Cuban music,
and she is in her car seat,
and her little legs
are, like, kicking.
I'm like, "Yep, that's my girl."
-Is he writing songs
for the baby?
He must be.
-He's got about a dozen now.
They're amazing.
That's what I sing all day
in my head are his songs to her,
because she just loves it.
She just is like, you know,
looks at her daddy,
and she just loves him so much.
She thinks he's the bee's knees.
It -- oh -- It makes my heart
just want to explode.
-I know Benj is involved
with this -- is it Veeps?
-Yes, with Veeps.
That's his platform
him and Joel started.
Artists can't go out and tour,
and we all know that's how
musicians and all artists,
people who pay --
you know, get paid
to be in a room,
they can't do that any longer.
So, they created
this platform where,
if artists can, you know,
take their livestreams
and make a living.
Because touring is not
coming back anytime soon.
-Do you remember
your first concert as a kid?
-Yes, I do.
-Oh, wait a sec. All right.
Wait. I'm already mad, 'cause
that's a very confident --
Yeah. What was it?
-Okay.
So, when I was 11,
1984, Van Halen, "Jump,"
was, like, my life.
It was my life.
-No. You did not see
Van Halen in 1984.
-At the Forum
here in Los Angeles.
My mother came home from work.
I had been sick that day.
She came home from work,
she said,
"I got a surprise for you,
but you have
to go to school tomorrow."
And I was like,
"Okay. What is it?"
And she was like --
One of her clients
had given her, like,
the loge seats on the side of,
like, right down by the stage
for Van Halen.
They were like,
"We don't need these,"
and my mom was like,
"My daughter loves Van Halen."
So it's me, 11, my sister, 13.
My mom goes, she drops us off
at the front where we go in.
She's in her Volkswagen bus,
she goes and parks,
she does her needlepoint
and drinks her wine
and eats her cheese in the car
while we're in the Forum
screaming our heads off.
And, Jimmy, when I say
screaming our heads off,
I mean, like,
I'm like, "I love you, Eddie!"
Like -- Like, blood
going down my throat
'cause I'm screaming so loud,
like crying.
It was, like, a Beatles moment.
And there was, like,
these girls behind us who were,
like, mature, young women
who, like, kept hitting us
and going, "Quiet!
Stop screaming! Stop it!"
The women in front of us
were turning around, going,
"Be quiet!" and me and my sister
were there just, like, dying.
We were losing our [bleep]
-And they are
an amazing live band.
I mean,
they are incredible live.
-Okay.
David Lee Roth,
at that time, in 1984,
was still capable of jumping
across the entire --
-With the boom box?
[ Both laugh ]
-He was like Michael Jordan
before Michael Jordan.
-[ Laughing ]
-He could jump that far
for that long.
-I got to see them when they had
a little reunion concert
at Café Wha? in New York,
in a tiny club,
and they sang "Panama,"
which is unbelievable, the song.
And they got to that one point,
where, like...
♪ And da, da,
ain't no stopping us ♪
And we all screamed like
♪ Pana -- ♪
But the band
didn't play anything.
They were like --
[ Clears throat, sniffs ]
-Shut up.
You know what?
-And then, they looked back,
and they're like...
♪ Pana-- ♪
And we all went, "Aah!"
It was awesome!
It was awesome.
-You're like, "Whaaat?"
-Yes!
It was the greatest thing
I've ever seen.
Best move in rock 'n' roll.
It so worked.
It tricked all of us.
-Took it to the next level.
-Oh, I...
-You know what I did
for my sister's 40th birthday?
Is Van Halen
was on their reunion tour
with David Lee Roth.
-Yeah.
So, I got tickets at, like,
the place that I could guess
was the closest spot to where
we were when we were 11 and 13.
And it was for the two of us,
and we went to The Forum,
and we went and saw Van Halen.
-That's cool.
That is cool.
See?
You just took cool one,
you took the next step cooler.
My first concert
was Weird Al Yankovic.
Oh, by the way,
that makes total sense.
[ Both laugh ]
I loved it,
I loved it.
You know, looking through
all your credits
and all the films you've made,
I didn't know --
I don't know why --
I just assumed
you already had been in movies,
but "The Mask"
was your first acting credit.
-"The Mask" was my first film,
and I turned 21
on the set of that film.
It was such
an amazing experience.
It changed my life forever.
What was I going to do
with my life at 21 years old?
Like, I had no plans, really.
I was just kind of, like,
hustling as a model, you know?
Like, just, I don't know.
Who knew?
-Yeah.
-You know?
-And you fell in love right
there and said, "This is it."
I got the bug.
This is what I want to do.
-You know, it was just like,
at 21 years old, you're like,
"Oh, I get to be around
a bunch of creative people
who all work as this
amazing team for the same --
you know, wanting to create
this one thing
that everybody's
just completely committed to."
And it was just this family
and comradery and just laughter
all day long,
that I was just like,
"I want to do this
all the time."
-Was it Jim Carrey's
first film, as well?
-No, but he had
already done "Ace Ventura,"
but it hadn't come out yet.
So, he was still the white dude
from "In Living Color."
-[ Laughing ]
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
He was just
on our show last week.
He has this new memoir out
that's really awesome
and different
and trippy and cool.
Was he great on set?
-Oh, my God, Jim was the best.
We had the best time,
really, honestly.
It was kind of like the end of
the innocence, in a weird way.
Because he hadn't
become Jim Carrey.
You know?
So there, wasn't all that
with him at that time,
even on set.
You know,
we were just kind of free.
And nobody knew
who I was, you know?
-Isn't that great?
You don't forget that.
-Yeah, it was really cool.
It was really cool.
And Jim was always --
you know, he's such a jokester,
and he's always
pulling jokes on everybody
and making things
so surprising all the time.
-[ Laughing ]
He's the best.
I want to talk to you
about Avaline, your new wine!
What are you talking about?!
What?!
It's real, it's real!
It's here!
It's gorgeous!
It's so fun!
Let's talk about it.
More with Cameron Diaz
when we come back, everybody.